قلعه معنويات الاوكرانيين كما سماها
زيلانسكي صامده حتى اللحظه فروسيا اقرت
بتراجع قواتها للوراء شماليه مدينه باخموت
اثره هجوم اوكرانيا جديد انسحاب وصفه رئيس
مجموعه
بل اتهم الجيش الروسي بالفرار من مواقعه
هذا التطور قطره من سيل هجمات لفظيه يواصل
شنها على القياده الروسيه لتطرح تساؤلات
عن سر تحمل الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
وقائد الثاني اقوى جيوش العالم لاهانات
رئيس مرتزقه ليس اكثر
معركه باخموت كانت الاكثر ابرازا لقوات
فاغنر غير ان ركود غضب بوتين تجاه تطاول
بريكوجين عليه لا يتوقف عند الدفع بقواته
ذات السمعه السيئه للجبهات الاماميه او
التضحيه بهم بل يرتبط بمجموعه حجج تعود
لحقبه ستالين وفق موقع فورنفرز
حاجه الرئيس الروسي الى قوات شبه عسكريه
تعود اولا لكبح جماح الجيش الذي طال ما
اعتبره تهديدا محتملا لحكمه فالجيوش تميل
بزمن الحروب الى اكتساب المزيد من القوه
داخل الدوله لدرجه يصعب احتوائها او
التحكم بها احيانا الاعتماد على فاجنر ليس
الا احدث تطور في تاريخ طويل من الاعتماد
الروسي والسوفيتي على قوات غير نظاميه
تقليد قديم يعود الى الحقبه السوفيتيه
عندما استخدم الكريم قوات بالوكاله للتدخل
في نزاعات حول العالم احدها الحرب الاهليه
الاسبانيه في ثلاثينات القرن الماضي بحجه
محاربه الفاشيه او ما عد لاحقا المقدمه
المباشره لمعركه روسيا الضخمه ضد النازيه
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه تبرير استخدمه
الكريم مجددا في اوكرانيا
ليبقى العامل الاكثر اهميه فيغنر المستمر
هو بوتين نفسه فابريجين لم يدخل دائره
التهديدات السياسيه المحيطه به ولا يزال
مفيدا حتى اللحظه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات